les bandes alimentaires du Québec n'ont
jamais été aussi sollicités en
contrepartie elle reçoit aussi moins de
dents
de 32% de la provisionnement des darrés
alimentaires comparativement à l'année
passée mais une augmentation de 27% des
demandes de panier d'alimentaire
l'organisme s'approvisionne à 33% des
dons en supermarché qui ont aussi
diminué ça s'explique par l'arrivée des
programmes arabais comme le fou des Road
de ce monde alors les dons qui nous
étaient habituellement donnés sont
revendus à 20 30% de rabais les
dirigeants derrière ces applications qui
permettent de trouver pour moins cher
des aliments jugés en fin de vie se
défendent ils disent faire partie de la
solution pour entre autres enrayer
l'insécurité alimentaire
par épicerie par année qui est jeté donc
redresser ce problème là vraiment pas
pour enlever de la nourriture manque va
vraiment se concentrer sur des petits
volumes d'avendu tout à fait
imprévisible et puis qui ont aussi une
durée de vie assez courte des
applications proposent même aux
commerçants et aux consommateurs
d'effectuer des dons aux Banques
Alimentaires les applications on sait
que c'est un effet ça affecte un peu
notre approvisionnement de données mais
c'est pas les faits principales selon
moi pour le directeur de l'organisme la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre dans les
supermarchés explique la diminution des
dons fait qu'on doit constamment former
de nouveaux employés sur ce qu'on peut
récupérer ou non les banques
alimentaires ont donc dû aller chercher
une centaine de nouveaux détaillants
pour réussir à augmenter de 1%, le
nombre de denrées recueilli en épicerie
dans la dernière année on est passé de
environ 450 à
560 détaillants l'année passée et on
continue nos efforts à ce niveau-là le
réseau provincial d'y répondre à 2,2
millions de demandes tous les mois des
données qui ont augmenté de 20% entre
2021 et 2022
ici Louis et des barcelonas au Canada
qué